[Music]  air  i saw a dappled wonder  settling across the fields hovering  on angel wings brandishing  a blazing shield  [Music]  where do they go the ones that run away  and  never return  there is nothing here but suffering  pain and suffering it is time to go  girl in that bulletin is wanted for the  murder of a child  man lost my mom then me  ain't no way he ever given up on finding  me  what's the worst yeah of you the worst  guy  the savagery man is capable of  when he believes his cause to be just  you came all this way on the railroad  yeah left behind all those peoples  [Music]  nothing was given  hold on to  what belongs to you  what's my name  [Music]  uh  you